[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier matin se levait sur le
deuxième jour de la planète chaleur
c'était inespéré
la planète des enfants de shadow match
se joue là ils l'appelèrent but dit
étant donné que b était le deuxième
maire de la londe un château aux beaux
souvenirs
[Musique]
malheureusement ce jour là le tout était
à l'eau on qu'ils avaient créées nous
ils ne s'étaient pas doutées que l'eau
serait comment dirais je serais si
aqueuse
[Musique]
alors il dira que le sam a sonné ce lieu
pour que paraisse le sec
est ce qu'il ya de plus rigolo c'est que
lou voulu bien sam à cerner la main des
eaux ils l'appelèrent mais on chat d'oc
duc laisser paru ils l'appelèrent la
tête au château des ducs à la mer du bus
avaient le droit par contre j'ai quand
même un petit peu et de faire des vagues
et des marées et les shadoks pire que
cela était beau
[Musique]
mehdi qui sur le dos tourné
lou en profita pour se déguiser en
vapeur d'eau est remonté qu'on laisse ça
faisait des nuages qui tombait sur les
enfants shadow qui n'en pouvaient tenait
alors il dire qu'il y est un firmament
ou 1 h 1 comme ça au milieu du ciel pour
séparer les au dessus des eaux du
dessous des rues bien un genre de
firmament mais malheureusement il était
percé d'eau tomber n'importe comment et
n'importe quand et naturellement que
jamais il faut dire que ça ne s'est pas
améliorée depuis et qu'on a toujours
autant d'ennuis avec la météorologie et
les shadoks dire que cela n'était pas
prêt heureusement la nuit fin fin du
second jour château il y eut un soir il
y aurait il encore un autre matin
[Musique]